[Music]
we're talking mainly about Trump who I'm
sure lots of people in this tent think
is a bit of a buffoon but paradoxically
perhaps his foreign policy is actually
achieving something and we're here to
question whether perhaps playing the
strong man on the world stage and being
unpredictable might actually make the
world a safer rather than a more
dangerous place who knows and we're
going to be arguing about that does that
sort of policy a strongman policy
unpredictable slightly crazy policy make
the world safer or more precarious so
first of all we're going to start with
George Galloway George I'm sure you know
he's been a Labour MP an MP for respect
his own party and he's the author of I'm
not the only one and the Fidel Castro
handbook George and the Neil Lennon
story don't forget that ah sorry celtic
France the brochure asked can a
belligerent foreign policy lead to
stability in the world like we've never
tried that before in fact the world is
in chaos precisely because of a
belligerent foreign policy and sometimes
the belligerents are mad like Donald
Trump bad like Tony Blair imbecilic like
George W Bush but they were all
exponents or of and practitioners of a
belligerent foreign policy and the
results are there for all to see the
question seems premise on the assumption
that we have had a non belligerent
foreign policy at any point in modern
history in fact since the United States
was born it has been a war all but one
year all but one year in its entire
lifetime and the last time Britain had
no soldiers fighting abroad
and only briefly was in 1779 so we have
had not just a lifetime of but centuries
of foreign policy belligerents and it
doesn't flow from any psychopathic
character necessarily although some like
Richard Nixon in his belligerent foreign
policy was undoubtedly psychopathic like
his foreign policy guru seems to have
been the guru to many including the
aforementioned Tony Blair Henry
Kissinger were undoubtedly psychopathic
but it doesn't necessarily require that
it requires a view of the world that the
rich and powerful have the right to
dictate to the less rich and less
powerful the the people who can do if
you can conquer other people's countries
in the past or conquer their economic
reality if not their territory as
happens more often nowadays if you can
you do and that's why we have chaos and
violence and the threat of truly
unbelievable levels of violence in front
of us today you asked Mary Ann about
Trump and his foreign policy let's
review it
Trump has unilaterally withdrawn from
the Iran nuclear deal signed Salomon
binding by his predecessor and the
permanent 5+1
and the Islamic Republic of Iran and
impeccably I'm using the words of the
IAEA impeccably observed by Iran Trump
has unilaterally with
from it begun a raft of ever deep and
punishing economic sanctions against
Iran and yesterday a major terrorist
atrocity was carried out by Saudi
sponsored which means American sponsored
terrorists in I was in Iran which killed
26 people now not just soldiers but old
soldiers paraplegic soldiers members of
the public in the crowd and journalists
covering the event we are headed
potentially to cataclysmic conflict
again in the Middle East what could
possibly go wrong
Iran will undoubtedly respond extremely
violently against Saudi Arabia at any
minute
certainly not long delayed that will be
get a response and so the spiral towards
war will twist Pompeo the US Secretary
of State the former head of the CIO CIA
this week threatened actions against
Venezuela they've already got sanctions
almost uncountable number of them now
it's us actions against Venezuela that
we can expect in the next few days and
the elephant in the room the morass of
the Syrian war some of you know me from
my stand against the Iraq war I'm here
to tell you that the involvement of
Western countries in the Syrian war is
the worst thing we have ever done ie
worse than Libya worse than Iraq our
belligerent foreign policy
of arming financing propagandizing for
Isis al-qaeda and the alphabet soup of
Islamist fanaticism in Syria is the
worst thing that we have ever done and
notwithstanding that the war is almost
over we may very well be about to double
down to double our bets on the
catastrophic conflict in Syria
so can a belligerent foreign policy
bring about peace and stability in the
world not bloody likely
[Applause]
thank you George Wright mark Leonard
here is a political scientist and he's
the co-founder and director of the
European Council on Foreign Relations
and is the author of why Europe will run
the 21st century
I nearly read ruin over to you mark so I
agreed with the last sentence that
George uttered but I do think that
there's a fundamental problem with the
way that he laid out his case which is
that he's normalizing Donald Trump and
just putting him into a continuum of
Western foreign policy over the last few
decades but I think the reason we're
having this debate is that something
quite fundamental is happening there is
a fundamental disruption in Western
foreign policy which is deeply troubling
and deeply worrying and one of the ways
that you can see how much the world is
changing and how quick the chaos which
Donald Trump has unleashed
is going through our our political
systems our international institutions
is the fact that even Donald Trump jokes
getting out-of-date very quickly during
the election campaign in Conan O'Brien
quipped the 70% of Americans we're
deeply
worried about the idea of a trump
presidency and 30% were becoming
Canadian but if he was making the joke
now he'd realized that the last thing
anyone want to do is to become Canadian
because Donald Trump seems to have a
particular animus against America's
northern neighbor and sees it as one of
the the worst
foes of the American system and I think
the reason for that is that he has a
fundamentally different worldview from
President Obama President Bush Bush the
father Clinton Reagan or any of the
other presidents that have been in power
at least in the last 100 years and I
think there's three things which are
uniquely worrying about Trump as
president the first is that he is the
only u.s. president in my lifetime who
has seen the International order as
something which undermines rather than
enhances American power in the world and
I don't think that he thinks that that
order doesn't benefit the West and
benefit the US but he does think that it
benefits others more in particular China
and his starting point is that if he
does nothing at all he will be the
president that oversees the relative
decline of his great nation and that
China will become the most powerful
country in the world because every year
China becomes stronger and richer and
the US in relative terms even though it
grows is becoming smaller and he but he
thinks that the entire establishment and
the elite is so wedded to this ordering
this way of doing things that it's
incapable of reforming it and therefore
what I think he's trying to do is to
launch a process of Schumpeterian
creative destruction where the first
instance is to blow everything up with a
view then to renegotiating the order on
terms which he thinks are more
beneficial to the US because he thinks
the paradox of the status quo is that
America is paying a lot of money is
losing a lot of lives in order to
sustain an order which is helping China
more than America and that's why he's
blah
the jcpoa vrr nuclear deal which George
was talking about why he's trying to
blow up the World Trade Organization why
he's threatening NATO why he's
withdrawing from almost everybody that
you can think of in the United Nations
it's because these are part of an order
which he thinks the u.s. is trapped in
which constrains it and above all in his
very zero-sum mind these are all
institutions which empower the week over
the strong and America is the strongest
than the most powerful country in the
world so therefore any institution which
brings countries together to negotiate
with the u.s. is one which in relative
terms weakens the US and strengthens
other countries against it and that's
why these institutions need to be
destroyed that's why he talked about the
European Union as a foe and even though
we are the closest allies of the US and
have been for decades because he thinks
that the you as it was designed to
weaken the US and to strengthen weak
European countries and then I think
stage two in this process of
Schumpeterian creative destruction is to
try and renegotiate an order on
bilateral terms where the US deals with
every single country on a one-to-one
basis so it can do it from a position of
strength and make the new order cheaper
and less constraining but the impact of
that is really to to destroy all of the
advances which have been made in the
last few decades and I find George's
characterization last few decades is
very strange like my mother is a German
Jew she was born in exile in in France
most of her family were wiped out in
concentration camps
my father is British but his earliest
memories of being evacuated as an
eight-year-old during the Second World
War his father got gassed in the First
World War the fact that my generation
and my kids who are sitting in the front
can look forward a sort of world where
the idea of war between European
countries is unthinkable where they can
travel without showing their passports
from one country to another and where we
have law-based controlled ways of
dealing with disagreements between
countries it's an incredible advance I
don't want to minimize
the catastrophe of the Iraq war or all
of the other mistakes and belligerent
act of Western foreign policy over the
last few decades but we live in a
completely different world it's a world
that is being threatened by Donald Trump
and by what's happening at the moment
and that brings me to the second threat
of Donald Trump as president which is
the fact that going back to my Canadian
example the people that he feels the
greatest animus to our American allies
because they're the ones who are
propping up the system the most so he
thinks that they are the number one
enemies in his process of disrupting the
global order that's why he's much more
comfortable dealing with Vladimir Putin
or Kim jong-un than dealing with Angela
Merkel and the fact that he's
undermining US alliances means for every
single part of the world where order has
been based on alliances with the United
States is becoming much more unsafe
that's true of Europe it's true of Asia
it's true of the Middle East and what's
happening is two things are going on as
American alliances become questioned and
people don't know whether they can count
on normal Trump to back them up the
American allies are having to hedge
against being abandoned by the United
States so they're having to rethink
their options to rearm and to up their
military spending at the same time the
enemies of the United States its rivals
also wondering whether the u.s. is going
to back up their allies so they're
testing out how far America will stand
by its allies and they're also
encouraged to rearm and to behave in
belligerent ways so in every theater of
the world what we're going to see over
the next few years and new levels of
instability new levels of violence and
the the problems which George Galloway
was talking about in the Middle East and
not about Western foreign policy and us
arming relatively dysfunctional groups
in Syria it's about the fact that there
was an order which was guaranteed by
Western powers which has now disappeared
and that's created a space where Iran
and Saudi Arabia and others who were
held together in place by a system and
now testing out their power and fighting
death and nobody cares about what
they're doing and no one's trying to
stop them and there are no limits
on the instability which can happen as a
result of that and the third thing which
I'd like to end with about Donald Trump
which is something which I don't think
we should normalize either it's not him
as an individual his unpredictability
his misogyny his racism and all the
horrible and disreputable functions of
Donald Trump but it is the philosophy
which he embodies which he's a symptom
of the idea of trumpism and that is
cancer which has taken hold in all
Western developed societies where a
large number of people who feel that
they've been left behind by established
politicians and by established political
parties who do not feel that they've
benefited from the advances which I
described earlier and actually rather
than seeing a world of greater
opportunity they feel threatened by a
lot of the infrastructure of the
globalized world whether it's free
movement free trade and they feel
nervous about their nature the culture
of their communities changing the
economic circumstances their job
security being changed in a world where
the West and the developing that
developed countries feel that they're
being kind of marginalized by a rise of
of others and that that's coming into
our own societies and that plays to a
politics of what is called the political
scientist called the threatened majority
when the people who felt that they're in
power now worried that every other kind
of minorities being mobilized against
them and that therefore a ripe for
manipulation by political figures
whether it's Faraj in this country
Donald Trump in America marine lepen in
France the IVD in Germany and if these
political forces succeed to work
together as we've seen happening with
with salvini in Italy and all-bad in
Hungary they're not just going to turn
our own countries into much less safe
and and comfortable places to live but
they could actually join Donald Trump in
dismantling this global order which has
made my lifetime much more comfortable
much safer and much less threatening
than that of my parents or grandparents
it looks like I gonna have to play
devil's advocate here so if you are
America and you have been the leading
member of NATO for the past whatever it
is sort of 60 odd years
Santiago and you have spent twice as
much of your GDP sometimes three times
much of your GDP on defense and you've
watched the other European members of
NATO free-riding on your defense
expenditure don't you have a right to
say come on guys shape up pull your
weight absolutely I mean I think the
Europeans need to take responsibility
for their own affairs we have achieved
incredible things in our own continent
in the last few decades and it's only
been possible because this remaking of
the European order has been done under
an American security blanket which
Europeans have not paid for I think in
the early years and decades after the
the the Second World War as someone from
a German Jewish background I think it
was probably healthy for Germany not to
be spending five ten percent of its GDP
on defense but I do think in the long
term it's obscene for three hundred and
fifty million Americans to be paying for
the security of five hundred million
Europeans that were as rich as them and
our interests are not the same and
Trump's actually showing how dangerous
it is for us to put our security in the
hands of the incumbent of the White
House not because America is a uniquely
evil or dangerous country in fact you
know if any country was going to be a
superpower of velocity decades I think
we America was definitely the one that I
would most have wanted to be in that
position but we're seeing whether it's
over the Iran nuclear deal whether it's
about Jerusalem as capital of
recognizing Jerusalem as capital of
Israel whether it's how we deal with
Turkey our interests are not identical
with American interests and if we don't
take responsibility for our own affairs
then we'll find ourselves unable to to
do things which are which are right for
our societies or
and also to stand up for the kind of
rule-based order which Europeans believe
in so I agree with the critique that
Europeans should spend more on European
defense so we need a more kind of
grown-up relationship with the US where
we're dealing with the more as equals
but I think that the amount of money the
US has paid for towards NATO the last
few decades is very cheap compared to
the amount of money that American
citizens taxpayers have to pay to get
involved in World War one in World War
two or during the Cold War where they
were dealing with Europeans being kind
of belligerent being at each other's
throats and having more kind of
militarized societies so I'm not sure
that that his solution to the problem is
is one which will actually be in
America's long term interests but I do
hope that Europeans take this as a
wake-up call because the world is very
very fragile at the moment it's not just
Trump it's Xi Jingping in China it's a
Diwan in Turkey it's Putin in Russia
there is a universalization of this kind
of strong man foreign policy and the
world around us is becoming much much
more unsafe and if we really believe in
what we managed to achieve over the last
few decades then we need to stand up and
and be willing to defend it and that
can't just be with great speeches or
even by taking out economic sanctions
against people who are threatening that
order I think ultimately we have to have
the full range of tools and that
includes military power George well as
half an irishman I'm entitled to see as
the irishman apocryphally did when asked
the road to London I wouldn't have
started from here the exceptional
ization of Donald Trump to which you've
just been listening is absurd Donald
Trump's been the president of the United
States for less than two years did the
chaos in the world start less than two
years ago it's utterly ridiculous the
crooner your idol
nice soup Barack destroyed Libya and
turned it into a slave market and a
jihad market for at least seven heavily
armed different Islamist groups wasn't
Trump that did that was Obama that did
that you have the goal to pray and eat
George W Bush is somehow better than
Donald Trump George W Bush and your
other hero Tony Blair killed a million
people in Iraq and rising spawned Isis
cascaded across the world you see how
happy how smug you are about the
rules-based society that we had before
Donald Trump 23 months ago 22 months ago
where was the rules-based order in the
invasion and occupation of Iraq and
utterly illegal act the consequences of
which will still be feeling in a hundred
years from now where was the rules-based
in the destruction of Yugoslavia no
international law no United Nations
Security Council unilateral use of
Western power deployed by the people
you're trying to persuade us were better
than Donald Trump
Vietnam was leveled bombed back to the
Stone Age
drowned in chemical weapons by Richard
Nixon and by Lyndon Johnson they were a
part of this rules-based complacency of
which you speak and in age of your
argument you draw attention to the fact
that populist SAR coming to power the
populist Tsar coming to power precisely
because of the failure of your
international
order precisely because of the failure
of your orthodoxy it's because
neoliberal politics totally filled in
Italy that you have the government in
Italy you have ditto in Hungary get all
the rise although it's stopped now you
may have noticed that melon shone with
whom I agree in every particular is now
the most popular politician in France
not lepen she's gone off for psychiatric
treatment the the rise of Trump the rise
of Corbin the rise of the right and the
populace in Italy are all because of the
failure of this order which you so
smugly wish to return us to I don't
think it was about foreign policy charge
to be honest the reason these populist
have been so successful is because of
domestic discontent separate economy
average voter on the doorstep who's
voting for Donald Trump is not talking
about Syria they're talking about jobs
in fact really the reason for the rise
of the populist in Italy is why because
the country has been flooded by millions
of refugees from the wars begun by your
heroes first of all let mark defines
himself first all as long as I think
you're both getting a very fair crack
right now I might spike him for longer
but I wasn't accusing you of worshipping
heroes that you didn't worship so maybe
I can sort of try and take a step back
from your very powerful rhetoric and say
first of all the fact that we can talk
about breaches of the rules-based order
like what happened in Iraq is because
you called it a mistake no it's a breach
it's a million people dead for God's
sake well who died sanctions beforehand
according to people who were who were
criticizing it before Saddam Hussein
killed many many people I was against
the war in Iraq and I'm still against
the war in Iraq nothing has happened
over the last 15 years to change my mind
about that but I think is the very fact
that there was an order that we can
recognize that as a breach of the order
now what makes me slightly uncomfortable
about your rhetorical flourish is that
you put all of these different things
that are quite different on the same
level you know what happened in Vietnam
will happen in Iraq being put on the
same level as intervening to stop
genocide in Kosovo I find strange
they're not you know not every type of
use of violence I think using violence
is always bad but sometimes it's the
leaf bad option
I think the second world war was
justified given what Hitler stood for I
think intervening in Kosovo was
justified in order to stop a genocide
and where lots of innocent people were
being what you send in Libya well I was
not particularly being war I think with
hindsight what we can see is genocide
and Libya genocide and Qasim okay I'm
not sure exactly if everything's
genocide then it basically normalizes
the idea of genocide for me you stopped
talking about that
well because where genocide once about
my family that was actually wiped out
there's no general say that costume
right there was ethnically and people
because no general sight well yes thank
you
so you got a microphone on you don't
need to shout okay so I I do think that
it's important not to toss words like
genocide about green it's also important
not to put every single foreign policy
decision that you disagreed with on the
same level there there is the fact that
there was a rules-based order means that
we can see the breaches of that order
and that is what's being destroyed and
to see I I hated George Bush he was my
least favorite American president until
Donald Trump was it was elected I was
absolutely disgusted by I wrote a whole
book against Bush's foreign policy back
in 2004 but at the same time I do think
that he was a fundamentally different
figure from Donald Trump because he
basically believed in the existence of a
rule-based order and he was pushing to
change it Donald Trump wants to blow the
whole thing up and to bring us to a
stage of Ag of Anarchy where the only
thing that matters is the law of the
jungle and where the strong decide what
happens and the weak have to do what
they tell them to do and I don't want to
live in in that world and I think if you
can't see the difference between those
two situations and you just normalized
Trump and put him into some kind of
continuum of betrayal which goes back
you know centuries like you did
beforehand and everything is genocide
and every military campaign is equally
bad then it's impossible to have a
serious discussion about what we're
trying to do in this world I do think
that they've been all sorts of mistakes
made over the last few decades I'm a
Social Democrat I'm not a neoliberal I
think that a lot of these populist
parties are coming to to power because
of a failure of domestic politics I
think some of the leaders like Jeremy
Corbyn are there because the failures of
foreign policy there would be no Corbin
if there hadn't been an Iraq war that is
clear to me but I think it is important
to try and hang on to what matters in
these things because if you're not you
end up in a kind of nihilistic place
like where everything is equally bad and
where the solution is where you just
sort of
have nothing constructive to say about
anything because everyone is a war
criminal everyone is equally evil
everyone is is is kind of genocide or
and that completely undermines any
critique that we have of what's
happening at the moment which I think
it's really worrying and scary and needs
to be stopped
can we talk a bit more about what what's
happening at the moment in relation to
North Korea which is something we
haven't mentioned yet so some people are
saying okay a few months ago three or
four months ago we were worried about a
nuclear war in North Korea
now we've got Kim jong-un meeting with
the president of South Korea
deciding to bid to host the Olympics
together agreeing to denuclearization
and that that is down to Donald Trump's
tough foreign policy know what I mean I
think his foreign policy has worked
incredibly well on one country in the
world and that's China I was in China a
few weeks ago and was very struck but
they see Donald Trump in completely
different terms to how he's seen in the
West most of my American friends and all
of my European friends see Trump as you
described it at the beginning as a kind
of buffoon who's self-defeating and kind
of destructive and doing all sorts of
things which which undermine American
interests and I do a kind of fundamental
level as I said I'm first answer but at
the same time in China they think that
he he's both their kind of master
strategist and a master tactician but he
basically pushed they think that he's
been declaring war on them on kind of
three fronts on an economic front on the
kind of political front and an
ideological front and they use North
Korea as the kind of prime example where
he ups the ante creates a real sense of
crisis puts the Chinese government under
so much pressure to introduce sanctions
that they shift their position six or
seven times he they get to the point
where the North Koreans almost see the
South Koreans has kind of sworn enemies
their closest allies with the only
country that they have a treaty
relationship with and then when he
realized to say he's run out of Road he
shifts tack basically tries to do a deal
and and then opens up a new front with
the Chinese entree
which we're now on at the moment and I
think actually you know having seen
various different presidents and lots of
Europeans fail to make any headway on
the Chinese there is some kind of logic
in terms of how he's handling with China
is he helping on North Korea and I think
it's much too early to tell I'm happy
that they're talking rather than him
threatening to you know tweeting about
Rocketman and threatening pre-emptive
nuclear strikes at the moment but I do
worry that as a result of mistakes in in
Western foreign policy of lost few
decades we created very perverse
incentives for the for the North Koreans
having seen what happened to Saddam
Hussein to Gadhafi I think it's quite
difficult to see why North Korea
wouldn't want to have nuclear weapons
and why North Korean leader wouldn't
want to have nuclear as a white trust
Western assurances that we will not try
and change the regime if if they get rid
of their nuclear weapon so I'd be amazed
if they really do do that and then it
ripping up the Iran nuclear deal exactly
the moment that you're trying to do a
deal with the North Koreans on nuclear
weapons seems like a inexplicable and
sort of catastrophic decision so we'll
see what happens I also worry that if
this fails as it's quite likely - it
will then empower the Hawks like John
Bolton within the administration who
want to go back to using military
solutions against North Korea and I
think that is the the scariest thing so
I do think we have every incentive to
try and make this work as much as
possible I think that you have very wise
leadership being shown by the South
Korean authorities that have been trying
to handle and to manage Trump but
they're in a very risky position because
they exposed themselves enormously and
Trump is totally unreliable and
unpredictable and that could be another
big casualty of this affair but I think
you know the time to make pass judgment
on his on his North Korean diplomacy is
probably in sort of five or six years
time rather than the
yeah okay so George we've heard a very
passionate denunciation from you of the
rules-based international order can you
tell us what you think should replace it
and and don't shout please because
you've already got a mic mic on and I
think it's just too loud for everybody
kindly let me decide the tone of voice
in which I well it has my ears
we don't want another half-life of a
conflict between you and I the Donald
Trump is an unpredictable unstable
person it's not strong and stable genius
he's a bull in a china shop and to mix
the metaphor even a stop clock is Right
twice a day
and he was right to meet with the North
Korean leadership and he was right to
encourage a rapprochement between North
and South Korea and it's going
swimmingly
in fact it's practically a love-in the
Koreans are embracing each other with a
warmth and vigor that no one could
possibly have imagined and Donald
Trump's predecessors would never have
permitted this is important Barack Obama
would never have met kim jeong-hoon
and therefore the permafrost of north
south korea relations would have
continued so and not only would Barack
Obama not have done it Hillary Clinton
would not have done it and so if we are
looking objectively at this thing you
have to see that Trump was right about
Korea and the others were wrong because
Korea has been for decades a clear and
present danger to world peace and and
stability it's not I'm passionately
denouncing the rules-based international
order
I am passionately denouncing the fact
that there is no rules-based
international order you just called
lawlessness a rules-based international
order with
mistakes some breaches but how many
breaches does it take to invalidate your
thesis in the first place if you have
what you call an international rules
based system in the world which is not
just breached not just mistakes but
which kills millions of people and
renders the whole world completely
unstable how many times does that need
to happen before your thesis is
invalidated now for most people it long
ago ceased to be credible to call it a
rules-based international order and I
refuse to accept your thesis that's all
I haven't got a thesis I'm just asking
you to what you think well you think
this is that there is an international
rules based all I see and and and my
case is that it's abundantly clear that
there has not been and that therefore
attempts to exceptional eyes Trump which
is the liberal mantra and nonsense he's
only been in 23 months so if we have the
world was in total chaos before he came
so so if we hadn't had the United
Nations and NATO set up after the Second
World War
do you think the world would have been a
better place no because I believe in a
United Nations with real authority but
as long as you have veto powers it
cannot possibly guarantee international
order
I support the United Nations it's it's
Tony Blair and George W Bush that walked
out of the United Nations and caused the
Cataclysm which is being I think
underappreciated here of the Iraq war
not since the first world war did we
take a decision that would so change the
world as the decision to invade Iraq now
the United Nations dicted the late Kofi
Annan
described that at the time as an indigo
act and yet it was carried out by people
who pretend that they are presiding over
a rules-based international order lost
lost point mark you know we're going
around in circles a bit but what happens
is that there's a certain point where
utopianism becomes nihilism if you say
that the order is not perfect that there
all sorts of things wrong with it and
therefore it's the same as have been no
order at all
that's a circular argument from my
perspective I think it's better for us
to have an idea about what kind of order
we want to live in it's something which
you have to fight for it you're fighting
against the laws of history for most of
human history there has been no such
thing as the rule of law we've lived in
the kind of jungle where might makes
right and over the last century there in
fits and terms they've been attempt to
try and bring some kind of structure to
try and regulate the relationships
between countries it's not been a linear
process it looked like there was a lot
of progress a hundred years ago and then
we had the Second World War and then the
Cold War but after the end of the Cold
War
I think enormous advances were made in
protecting human rights in setting up
institutions to deal with the climate
crisis to deal with genocide to make
sure that you didn't have trade wars
between different countries and it's
imperfect and it still allows hypocrisy
and it's easier for strong countries to
get their way than weaker countries and
there's racism and there all sorts of
horrible things that have happened and
I'm not defending any of them but I
think that the attempt to do it is
something which is noble and is worth
while and is something that should be
supported the fact that we are trying to
do it
also allows us to see where we fall
short of those of those aspirations and
there are lots of examples of it
countless examples of it but it doesn't
mean that we shouldn't keep trying and I
do think that Donald Trump is not just
somebody who's behaving outside of that
system
he's acting against that system and
trying to destroy it and that's why he
is a kind of unique threat to what has
been achieved over the last few decades
and I think he should be called out as
that rather than just seen as part of a
kind of history of lawlessness and to
pretend that this project hasn't been
there and that these institutions are
not there even if they are often you
know undermined and we don't live up to
them but the very fact that you can talk
about an illegal act means that there's
a law if there's no law you can't talk
about an illegal act
thank you thank you very much to both of
you thank you all for coming
Arsen ideas her AI TV
you